da der butator oder wie schon
Präsidenten ich würde mich an die
Abgeordneten den Präsidenten und alle
anderen hier vertretenden
ich werde dich an sie am heutigen Tage
als Ministerpräsidentin
und möchte sie um etwas bitten
ich möchte Sie auffordern das Vertrauen
einer von Mai von mir geleiteten
Regierung auszusprechen das ist eine
große Verantwortung die ich übernehmen
will und das Vertrauen ist dafür
erforderlich wäre es von stabiliter
große Verantwortung also
für die ganz einfach
allgemeine Anerkennung und Vertrauen
nötig sind es steht um unsere Demokratie
und wir dürfen in dieser Lage uns nie
der Verantwortung entziehen ich möchte
also dementsprechend sofort
denen danken die ihre Überzeugungen hier
in diesem Saal vortragen unabhängig von
den Aussagen
danke aufrichtig dem Präsidenten der
Italienischen Republik Sergio materella
der
Espresso im Klaren Wunsch der
Italienerinnen und Italiener bei den
letzten Wahlen Folge geleistet hat und
wertvolle Ratschläge erteilt ich danke
natürlich auch den Parteien der
Regierungskoalition
mein fratelli Italia der Lega
Forza Italia wieder und ihren führenden
Persönlichkeiten
die rechte Mitte muss sich bewähren sie
hat an der Wahlurne Bestand gehabt und
muss nun in diese Regierung in kürzester
Zeit in unserer vulkanischen Geschichte
etwas leisten
[Applaus]
dass wir erhalten haben
wir müssen verschiedene Sensibilitäten
überwinden weil es an höheres Interesse
für uns alle gibt digitale mai ranked
eurosa das ist eine Pflicht die uns
allen auferlegt ist unter den
schwierigsten Bedingungen in denen
Italien lebt
wir dürfen nicht schwanken wir dürfen
keine Zeit verlieren wir dürfen als
Italienerin Italiener unseren Kurs nicht
verlieren und danke auch meinem
Vorgänger
Herrn Präsident Mario Dagi für seine
Arbeit auf nationaler Ebene wie im
internationalen Bereich
diesen Wochen seine gesamte Bereitschaft
gezeigt dafür zu sorgen dass die
Stabübergabe die Amtsübergabe schnell
und zügig und ordentlich Erfolg ist
diese Regierung
wird
alle sehr gute Idee
stimmt durch auch die Rolle der
Oppositionspartei und wir haben diesen
Aspekt das ist eine Position bei uns
gibt natürlich berücksichtigt es ist ja
einfach so und so muss es immer sein so
ist es in allen großen Platinen
Regierung und Opposition stehen einander
gegenüber und Arbeiten für das
gemeinsame ganz
[Applaus]
an diesem Tag
darf ich festhalten dass ich als erste
Frau die Spitze die Regierung in unserer
Nation habe übernehmen dürfen
[Applaus]
die Verantwortung die ich trage auch für
alle Frauen die in diesem Augenblick
großen und ungerechten Schwierigkeiten
gegenüberstehen ihre Fähigkeiten
einzusetzen und zu nutzen oder überhaupt
ihre Rechte wahrzunehmen nachdem sie
jahrelang Opfer gebracht haben
ich denke daran mit Bedacht und mit
unserem Beispiel müssen wir vorangehen
wir müssen
die Glasdecke durchbrechen die auf uns
allen als Frauen gelastet hat
[Applaus]
gerne
Frauen haben von der Vernunft geleitet
und von der Liebe getragen dieses Ziel
angestrebt
Christina zum Beispiel die
Kulturveranstaltungen gemanagt hat oder
andere viele Frauen die ich hier als
Beispiel anführen könnte alt von
cinemannswegen die gegen den kalten
wintervorteile gekämpft hat in ihrem
Bereich oder Maria und Gracia die
Bildungsbereich Kindern aus allen
Ländern Hilfe geleistet haben
[Applaus]
dafür dass Sie die Werte der Jenischen
Frau hochgehalten haben und ich hoffe
dass ich Ihnen ebenfalls gerecht werden
kann diesen Ansprüchen
war mein Dank gilt natürlich vor allem
dem italienischen Volk das beschlossen
hat den großen das große Treff mit der
Geschichte einzuhalten und den
demokratischen Entwicklungen ihren Lauf
zu geben
das Volk ist der Träger der Souveränität
viele Jahre lang ist diese Bürgerpflicht
die in der Verfassung verankert ist
vernachlässigt worden häufig ist die
Wahlentscheidung der Bürger folglich
geblieben man hat darauf nicht
ausreichend Rücksicht genommen alles hat
sich den kleinen Salons oder exklusiven
Zirkeln abgespielt in den letzten Jahren
und Jahrzehnten
verfassungsrechtlich waren die
regierungsmehrheiten sicherlich in
Ordnung aber weit entfernt vor den
Bestrebungen der Wähler wir wollen heute
diese große italienische Anomalie
überwinden eine politisch Regierung
werden die wirklich repräsentativ ist
für den Volkswillen
die Rechte und Pflichten die sich aus
den Wahlen ergeben eine parlamentarische
Mehrheit
Regierungsführung für fünf Jahre Arbeit
nach dem besten unser Möglichkeiten im
Interesse der Nation
wir werden die Wahlentscheidung von
Millionen für ihre nicht nutzen um ein
Machtsystem durch ein anderes einfach zu
ersetzen
sie wollen die besten Energien unserer
Nation freisetzen und den Italienerinnen
und Italienern und zwar allen eine
bessere Zukunft in Freiheit
gewährleisten mir Freiheit mehr
Gerechtigkeit
wir Ausgleich und da müssen wir gegen
einige Machthaber Vorgehen die noch
nicht verstanden haben worum es geht und
viele leben noch in der Vergangenheit
und das können wir so nicht weiter
geschehen lassen
Wahlkampf habe ich ein Programm
vorgestellt für die künftige Regierung
wir die rechte bitte gewählt hat ist
jetzt hier vertreten und wir haben
unsere Verpflichtungen die Bindung
zwischen den Wählern und den gewählten
ist die Grundlage der Demokratie das
müssen wir sehen
es geht um die politischen Kräfte in der
Opposition die sicherlich einigen unser
Vorschläge nicht gut halten wollen aber
die Demokratie gehört nicht den einen
mehr als den anderen und ein
Wahlergebnis muss berücksichtigt werden
muss angenommen werden und die Umsetzung
darf nicht behindert werden
Tagen haben sich einige gemeldet die
sagten sie wollten über die neue
Regierung Wachen ich glaube sie könnten
ihre Zeit besser verwenden
ja im Parlament
in unserem Parlament
tapfere Kämpfer auch der Opposition
sicherlich vertreten aber alle sind in
der Lage die eigene Stimme zur Geltung
zu bringen ohne dass ich nachhelfen muss
und ich hoffe dass bestimmte Kräfte mir
zustimmen wenn ich sage dass es darum
geht wir müssen über Italien Wachen und
es geht darum dass unsere Regierung
nicht der Respekt verweigert wird und
schon gar nicht dem italienischen Volk
das keine leeren von anderen hören
sollte
mit vollem Recht Teil des Westens und
seiner Bündnisse hat die Europäische
Union mitbegründet die Eurozone und so
weiter wir sind Mitglieder der G7 und
den vielen anderen Gremien und wir haben
zusammen mit Griechenland die westliche
tivision begründet und das Wertesystem
das auf Freiheit gleich hatte Demokratie
beruht das sind kostbare Früchte die wir
schützen müssen und das ist die
christliche Grundlage Europas wir sind
die Erben des heiligen Benedikts eines
Italieners der für ganz Europa steht
ich möchte
in dieser Stelle wo ich von Europa
spreche zuerst mal
den verschiedenen Gipfeln hier sterben
gefunden habe ich danke den Vertreter
der EU-Kommission denn Michelle Frau von
der Leyen Frau Mezzola für das
Europäische Parlament Peter Fiala und
andere als Ratspräsident vielen anderen
die mir eine gute Arbeit gewünscht haben
es ist natürlich auch so dass ich merke
dass viel Interesse unserer Regierung
entgegengebracht wird was das Interesse
für europäische Fragen bei uns angeht
und da muss ich ehrlich sein italien
muss deutlich seine Stimme geltend
machen als große gründernation der
Europäischen Union
man darf die europäische Integration
nicht sabotieren nicht bremsen wie es in
diesen Wochen in der geheißen hat es
geht darum die richtigen Kurs zu steuern
auch in Krisen angesichts äußerer
Bedrohungen möglichst nah an den Bürgern
an den Unternehmen
wir müssen richtig verstanden werden wir
sehen die EU nicht als einen elitären
Zirkel wir sehen eher als eine
Gesellschaft in der wir
an dir unsere Völker denken müssen das
ist kein Verwaltungsrat in einer Firma
und die müssen in der Lage sein uns dem
großen Aufgaben unserer Zeit zu widmen
und die Mitgliedstaaten müssen Dinge
geregelt bekommen für europäische Ebene
die sie allein nicht schaffen wir müssen
uns gegenseitig helfen bei der Energie
bei der Migration beim Kampf gegen die
theoretismus das sind große Aufgaben
bei denen die op-union nicht immer sich
bereit gezeigt hat nicht immer so weit
war die kann es denn sein dass eine
Integration die über so viele Jahre
erfolgt ist jetzt als
platanunion eingeleitet heute so weit
gekommen ist dass die Zuständigkeiten
ganz anders verteilt sind gerade im
Bereich der Energie Sicherheit ist es
ganz anders gelaufen als wenn sich das
hätte wünschen können
wenn wir diese Fragen in den Raum
stellen
wenn wir das in Erinnerung rufen ist das
keine Ketzerei sondern Pragmatismus
wir haben keine Angst zu sagen darauf
hinzuweisen wenn etwas nicht
funktioniert wie es sollte es geht meine
effizientere Integration
entsprechend dem Gründer Motto
geeint in Vielfalt denn das ist die
große Besonderheit Europas wir haben
eine Jahrtausende alte Geschichte und
müssen in der Lage sein uns zu einigen
obwohl jeder die eigene Identität
besitzt im gemeinsamen europäisches Haus
bedeutet natürlich auch dass man Regeln
gemeinsam beachtet auch im finanziellen
Bereich diese Regierung wird die zurzeit
geltenden Regeln Bestimmungen beachten
und ein Beitrag leisten dort wo es noch
nicht funktioniert auch bei der
laufenden Diskussion über den Stabilität
zum Wachstumspakt
hat vor allem die Pflicht und das Recht
in diesem Zusammenhang international
dabei zu sein
konstruktiven Einstellung aber ohne
minderheits-
es geht um die Bestätigung der eigenen
nationalen Interessen
angesichts der gesamtaufgaben die vor
Europa und dem Westen liegen
[Applaus]
atlantische Bündnis garantiert unseren
Staaten Sicherheit und Italien ist
verpflichtet dazu in vollem Umfang
beizutragen denn Freiheit hat Ihren
Preis und dieser Preis für einen Staat
ist die Fähigkeit sich verteidigen zu
können und die Zuverlässigkeit die der
Staat in dem Bündnis dem er angehört
zeigt
wir haben viele internationale Missionen
gehabt bei denen wir die Federführung
gehabt haben und deshalb möchte ich auch
den Frauen und Männer unserer
Streitkräfte danken dafür dass sie das
Ansehen Italiens hochgehalten haben in
schwierigen Situationen um den Preis des
eigenen Lebens
höhere rigolo Shane das Vaterland ist
dafür stets dankbar